we long time tradition I'm not gonna  punch your way out of this  everyone yeah we don't really need to  start a conversation captain big fan  Captain America's at war captain you  chose the wrong side what do we do we  fight  suit up right behind you pal  this can't seem to miss let's go  Captain America sees  Twitter pg-13 seaton IMAX and  large-format may six we may not be  perfect Tony but the safest hands are  still our own sometimes I want to punch  you in your perfect teeth  we're still friends right  you just got complicated  captain  you seem a little defensive well it's  been a long day  quitter pg-13 seen an IMAX and large  format may say